he totally wrecked the economy doubled
our national debt more debt than every
other president before him combined he
failed to stop the rise of Isis billions
of dollars to the Iranian mullahs that
actually were chanting death to America
he ignored Putin's
master power massive power grab Crimea
Ukraine neglected the simmering crisis
in North Korea and yeah he's back just
in time for the midterm elections and he
wants to tell you how to vote earlier
today Barack Hussein Obama delivered
this so-called warning to America let's
take a look I'm here today because this
is one of those pivotal moments when
every one of us as citizens of the
United States need to determine just who
it is that we are just what it is that
we stand for and as a fellow citizen not
as an ex-president but as a fellow
citizen I'm here to deliver a simple
message and that is that you need to
vote because our democracy depends on
now what a sanctimonious one as Reagan
said stay the course
hey I'm former President Obama well he
is actually right about one thing
because in 60 days
remember 2016 was about the Forgotten
men and women in this country if you
don't go out and vote the consequences
will be dire the Trump agenda they will
stop in its tracks
Obama's friends in Congress that brought
us to the brink of economic catastrophe
and weakness and apology on the world
stage guess what they want power back
they want to stop Trump and they even
want to impeach them now we're gonna
have a important minion monologue about
the midterms you can't afford to miss
that's later in the show including more
of Obama's hypocritical self-righteous
remarks that should make your blood boil
all right but first our investigation
into the deep state rolls on tonight and
what we have now uncovered is now
beginning to connect all of the dots I
think we now understand what the
insurance policy is worse than we
originally thought the foundation of
this Republic is now shaken to its core
the biggest abuse of power scandal in
history you've got a few on
that high-ranking officials inside of
our government trying and almost
succeeding to alter the course of this
country's history at the very center of
it all is the man whose name should be
seared into your brain Bruce or he is
the face now of deep state corruption
and according to a damning investigative
report from the hills John Solomon in
the summer of 2016 it was or remember he
was the fourth highest ranking member of
the DOJ tampering with an ongoing FBI
investigation into so-called Russia
collusion why to destroy then candidate
Donald Trump we'll break it down step by
step layer by layer here's what we know
2016 Hillary Clinton wanted dirt on her
opponent Donald Trump this is after she
got her exoneration without an
investigation that's another part of the
story
her campaign in the DNC well they
funneled money through a law firm that
was called Perkins cuy that hires fusing
GPS and op research firm and then of
course they attempted to literally hire
a foreign national which we thought was
a bad thing for America that was
Christopher Steele former mi6 buy and
don't forget Natalie or is the wife of
DOJ official Bruce or she's working on
the phony what turned out to be Russian
dossier specifically Russian dirt that's
on Donald Trump that nobody bothered to
verify well not so coincidentally at the
same time the FBI was also paying
Christopher Steele they later fired him
for lying and leaking in their Russia
investigation but now we know that Bruce
or had his dirty little fingers all over
this it was Bruce or who pushed the FBI
to use the steals campaign opposition
research remember he was a hater he
wanted to stop Trump it was Bruce [ __ ]
meaning steal it was or who spread
steals phony dossier throughout the
federal government to lie to the
American people it was or who became a
back channel remember 70-plus contacts
with Christopher Steele even after he
was fired by the FBI for leading anti
Trump leaking it to the to the press in
this country that means to you it was
Bruce or who knew that Steele was
completely biased desperate to stop
Trump at all costs and that all wrote
that steal was passionate about Donald
Trump never being president Bruce or
knew that
CA was biased would never hold up in
court he knew it was tainted he knew it
was not verified or corroborated and yet
he pushed that information into the
Grateful hands of antitrump agent struck
and Lisa Paige and even the pit bull
himself Andrew Weissman so you got to
start with Hillary's campaign they fund
it they funneled the money it gets to a
foreign spy a foreign agent he puts in
the hates Trump he gets phony Russian
information its disseminated to you the
American people and it gets worse from
there none of this should happen in
America you have a political campaign
the DOJ working together coordinating
their efforts literally to stop one
candidate over another candidate this is
a humiliating smear on the country
system of justice and it gets worse
because the phony political dirty
Russian dossier that Hillary paid for
never verified was used as the very
basis for FISA warrants to spy on a
trump campaign associate let's see Jim
called me signed off on the Pfizer
request Sally Yates Dana bhante rod
Rosenstein Andrew McCabe all signed off
on it and tonight we can report that
fired deputy FBI director Andrew McCabe
is now facing a real serious criminal
investigation we know tonight a grand
jury has been impaneled by federal
prosecutors multiple witnesses have been
summoned as the former deputy director
is accused of using as a position to
advance his personal political interests
if justice is served the McCabe
investigation should just be the tip of
the iceberg
everyone who committed this fraud on the
FISA Court using unverified information
the steel dossier by a trump aider
probably should be investigated and
prosecuted
that would mean Comey and Yates in yeah
the guy that did the last one rod
Rosenstein the guy that appointed Muller
need to be held accountable
multiple Republican lawmakers now
demanding the president Declassified and
unredacted multiple FISA documents on
top of that the 302s as it relates to
Bruce or Christopher Steele and the gang
of eight material we're expecting the
president could make
this information available even as early
as this weekend now we're talking about
everything that the gang of eight had we
know the specific pages of FISA that we
had apparently exculpatory information
on coroner page and even somebody like
Papadopoulos who just was sentenced to
14 days in jail 28 million dollars later
this information must be released you
the American people have a right to know
how a fraud was committed on a FISA
Court against the Trump campaign
associate not once but multiple times
they never verified any of this
information it turned out to be false
they purposely omitted information that
would have had an impact on these judges
that's lying by omission and what we've
shown you each and every night right
here on this program is what is a scary
level of corruption that's only risen to
the surface because Hillary didn't win
in spite of all these efforts she won
we wouldn't know any of this the deep
state would be alive and well working
behind the scenes corruptly undermining
your vote what you want for your country
his biggest abuse of power scandal ever
no thankfully the president is he's
breaking up some China in Washington
he's smashing the status quo
he's shattering all the establishment
politics the old rules are gone that's
why one such cowardly bureaucrat who
claims to be a senior official in the
Trump administration acting out New York
Times op-ed claiming to be a part of the
so-called resistance really within our
government we have a resistance Wow we
have sleeper cells within our government
this is a clear and present danger to
the country now in an interview on Fox &
Friends the president slammed this
anonymous New York Times and The Times
itself for publishing this nonsense
take a look
on you as an attack on the people that
voted for you knowing who did it and
what should be done if you find out who
did it well number one the time she'd
never done that because really what
they've done is virtually you know it's
treason you can call it a lot of things
that is beyond unacceptable it's like a
soft coup aided and abetted by the
corrupt media in this country Washington
Post reporting sleeper cells within our
own government think about that inside
the administration what to undermine the
commander in chief does this so-called
senior official have a security
clearance access to top-secret
information sources methods and the
potentially compromised
is he here that president talking about
war and peace you know and look at this
particularly alarming part of the
article look at this we will do with the
what we can to steer the administration
in the right direction until one way or
another it's over one way or another
what is one way or another it will vote
it out and peached
died in office is that a veiled threat
where's the Secret Service either way
given this person alleged proximity to
the president it should be investigated
and treated as a matter of national
security
perhaps the president should used the
Obama model and tracked down the
anonymous Salvatore
according to reports no previous
president was more tough on leakers than
Obama I know shocking he subjected his
own staff to lie detector test
prosecuted multiple individuals targeted
members of the press who published
leaked stories including former Fox News
reporter James Rosen who was surveilled
even accused of being a co-conspirator
because he dared to report with
anonymous sources inside the Obama White
House that was Obama that did all that
meanwhile the super Patriot who authored
this op-ed in the New York Times if you
were truly working behind the scenes for
the benefit of the country why not stay
behind the scene why why risk exposure
in a very
public way because this individual
unelected and unaccountable they think
their truth is better than what the
president ran on what the American
people voted for and he's pushing their
political agenda he or her whoever it
happens to be that they know better than
we the smelling Walmart people and those
purr pinions are more value than than
your opinions but ultimately this is an
attack on the presidency and the country
the country can get hurt in this process
the very reason why President Trump and
the Secret Service now must do
everything in their power to dismantle
the deep state and find out whoever this
is